♪ J'aimerais tant m'envoler de mes propres ailes! ♪ Ik zou zo graag zelf vliegen!
Il y a quelqu'un?   Is hier iemand?
♪ Je veux tout ce que je n'ai pas... ♪   Ik wil alles wat ik niet heb......
Il faut que je vous voie.   Ik moet U zien.
♪ Je voudrait que ma vie change ♪      Ik zou willen dat mijn leven verandert.
Et si c'était celle qu'on attendait ?            En als zij het is, die wij verwachtten?
♪ Ça n'a vraiment rien d'étrange... ♪ Dit is toch helemaal niet vreemd.....
Ravi de vous rencontrer ! Zeer blij U te ontmoeten
♪ Ce monde est bien trop petit pour moi... ♪ Deze wereld is veel te klein voor mij......
Belle, ma chérie    Belle mijn liefje
Tu es tellement en avance sur ton temps.   Jij bent je tijd zo ver vooruit.
Et c'est un tout petit village! En het is een heel klein dorp.
Tu es la créature la plus somptueuse de tout l'univers.   Jij bent het prachtigste schepsel van het hele universum.
Personne n'est digne de toi. Niemand is jou waardig.
Les gens ont l'esprit étroit, voilà tout. De mensen hebben een enge geest, daar is alles mee gezegd.
Mais un village est plus sûr qu'une ville. Maar een dorp is veiliger dan een stad.
Je suis venue chercher mon père! Ik ben mijn vader komen zoeken.
Votre père est un voleur! Uw vader is een dief!
Il faut que je vous voie! Ik moet U zien!
Je m'enfuirai, je te le promet! Ik zal vluchten, dat beloof ik je!
Non! Neen!
Regarde! Une jeune fille!  Kijk! Een jong meisje!
Qui a dit ça ? Wie heeft dit gezegd?
Coucou!   Koekoe!
Vous parlez ? U spreekt?
Mais évidemment, il ne fait même que ça! Maar natuurlijk, hij doet alleen dat!
Je suis ravie de faire votre connaissance. Ik ben zeer blij kennis met U te maken.
Vous voulez voir ce que je sais faire? Wilt U zien wat ik doen kan?
Qu'arrivera-t-il quand le dernier pétale tombera? Wat zal er gebeuren als het laatste bloemblaadje zal afvallen?
Le maître demeurera une bête pour toujours. De Meester zal voor altijd een beest blijven.
Nous deviendrons de la camelote! Wij zullen bocht worden!
Que lui avez-vous fait? Wat hebt U hem aangedaan?
Rien! Niets!
Sortez d'ici! Ga hier weg!
Sortez! Naar buiten!
Il faut que vous m'aidiez! U zou mij moeten helpen!
Tâchez de vous lever. Probeer op te staan.
Si c'est bien elle... Als zij het inderdaad is....
Qui doit rompre le sort...   die het lot moet verbreken......
Vous devez enfin apprendre à aimer! U moet eindelijk leren liefhebben!
Avez-vous réellement lu tous ces livres? Hebt U echt al deze boeken gelezen,
Pas tous, certains sont en grec... Niet allemaal, sommige zijn in het Grieks...
Tuons la bête! Laten wij het beest doden!